thanks to brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video I have a cold by
the way scientists keep making
predictions that the world will warm by
one or two or three or however many
degrees it is in 30 years time but why
do they keep making these predictions if
none of them have been correct so far
you may remember climate scientist James
Hansen famously testifying to the U.S
Senate in 1988 that the world would warm
spectacularly in the coming decades yet
reality didn't match his predictions he
overestimated any warming by a factor of
at least two but what if I told you that
this graph has been doctored and that
the reality is much more shocking come
with me on a journey about predictions I
think you'll find it interesting
everyone knows that scientists make
regular die predictions about climate
change some suggest that they exaggerate
the threat in order to get more
attention and soak more funding so in
2020 NASA scientists performed an
analysis of computer models used to make
climate change predictions specifically
they looked at the models used in the
fourth ipcc report which you could argue
are the most important models because
the conclusions of the ipcc ports are
the headline news of climate science the
authors compared the predictions that
came out of these models with the NASA's
data set on Earth's surface temperature
and they found that the models were
pretty much bang on the models closely
matched observations up to 2004 which
makes sense because modelers would know
their models were bad if they didn't
match the observations to date but
impressively the models also accurately
predicted Global temperature increase
from 2004 to 2020 which is about 0.5
degrees Celsius or in other words all
those predictions you've heard in the
news about short-term climate change
have been on average correct the fact
that the forecast period looking
forwards in time is approximately as
accurate as the hindcast period looking
backwards in time indicates that the
assumptions made by the models about how
the atmosphere will respond to changes
in greenhouse gas concentrations are
appropriate they're accurate the paper
also looked at older predictions
including some made in the 1970s being
much older and so much more primitive
you'd expect these predictions to be
less accurate but compare the warming
observed since our model was created in
blue with the warming predicted by that
model in red some models overestimate
the warming the Red Dot was higher than
the blue While others underestimate the
warming but for almost all of the models
considered their predictions fall within
the error bars of observed warming in
other words even old relatively
primitive predictions of future climate
change have thus far been largely
accurate and further each model here
represents the Earth's system slightly
differently with some processes like
cloud formation or feedbacks and how
forests are responding to a changing
climate represented with different
numbers attached in the computer code
and this is why climate scientists and
indeed meteorologists use what we call
ensembles collections of statistical
models none of which are correct per se
but Each of which are a good
approximation of reality combine them
together though and you get something
that is greater than the sum of its
parts not a perfect representation of
reality but a robust statistical model
of it something that we can use to make
predictions so if past predictions of
climate change have been broadly
accurate and borne out by the data which
indicates that our current predictions
are probably going to be also why do we
think of climate change predictions as
being well pants well that has more to
do with us as humans rather than the
climate models themselves firstly any
long-term prediction needs
definitionally a long time to verify a
prediction about what the next 10 years
will look like needs 10 years in order
to work out if it was correct or Not by
which point almost everybody will have a
forgotten the prediction was made in the
first place and B forgotten exactly what
that prediction said you combine that
with the fact that science was within
statistically acceptable bounds again
isn't exactly headline news we almost
never hear of the long-term verification
of predictions perhaps in the absence of
verification we humans if we even
remember that our prediction was made in
the first place just tend to assume that
well it was probably wrong add to that
the fact that we as humans are terrible
at treating predictions and indeed facts
neutrally psychology experiments have
shown that humans often only accept
something as true if it supports what
they want to believe in something called
motivated reasoning we think this is
because it's psychologically easier to
reconcile any contradictions between the
evidence in front of you and your
feelings on a subject than it is to
revise those feelings that's something
that takes a lot of internal energy the
predictions made by climate scientists
that the world is fundamentally changing
getting warmer with more extreme weather
are scary and there are a lot of people
who simply don't want them to be true
and further there are plenty of people
who don't want those predictions to be
true because if they were
it would threaten their way of life this
brings us back to Hansen's prediction
and this graph because here's the thing
Hansen didn't make one prediction
he made three one assumed that
greenhouse gas emissions would increase
exponentially from 1988 one assumed that
emissions would increase but linearly
and the last assumed that emissions
would Peak around the year 2000 and then
decrease comparing all three predictions
to observations we see that Hanson's
scenario B is pretty close and that
additionally Hanson correctly predicted
the pattern of global warming with some
areas warming faster than others and the
Arctic warming fastest of all in other
words he did a pretty great job yet the
hand Supply is frequently shown with
only scenario a the most unrealistic and
the furthest from observations and this
deliberate Omission is done to Peddle a
narrative that climate science doesn't
know what it's doing and that global
warming isn't real and this is frankly
willful Distortion of very good science
to further an agenda that agenda is to
keep things running pretty much as they
are right now enriching the people that
are currently being enriched mostly
through the burning of fossil fuels the
next time that you see this figure being
shared or one that makes a similar kind
of argument have a look at who is
sharing it why they are sharing it and
if you're feeling particularly motivated
where their money is coming from because
it's almost certain that ultimately
money is coming from fossil fuel
interest groups I've said it before and
I'll say it again go and read merchants
of Doubt by nomia rescues and Eric
Conway it's really powerful stuff that
just might change the way that you look
at how global warming and several other
topics are covered in the news the
reason that we think climate change
predictions are pants isn't because of
the quality of the predictions but
rather which predictions we are shown if
you want to believe that climate change
isn't real you likely follow new sources
that only show you the predictions on
the extreme ends of the spectrum either
saying that mineral warming will take
place or that an absurd level of warming
will take place and thus that scientists
clearly don't know what they're doing
or of course you can just take stuff out
of context or willfully misrepresent it
that works too ultimately though for the
past four or five decades the science
has become increasingly clear the
predictions have been borne out by the
evidence scientists predicted that the
world would warm and it has at the rate
that most models predicted it would
this may be an uncomfortable even An
Inconvenient Truth but it is still the
truth we are in trouble whether you want
to believe that or not we can trust the
science and we can believe the
predictions that our models are
currently making
so let's do something together
to avoid some of the potential futures
that we see before us
do you find graphs like this quite
intimidating statistical literacy or
lack thereof is something that's been in
the news a lot recently knowing how to
read graphs like this one or being able
to see where statistics have been
misused like in this case or this case
or this case my God has become an
increasingly valuable skill if you want
to learn what you're being shown
actually means rather than just being
told then go and check out the course
statistics fundamentals on brilliant who
have kindly sponsored this video
brilliant is an educational app and
website that teaches you new skills or
allows you to freshen up old ones
through interactive courses the idea is
to get far away from rote learning and
memorization and instead learn by doing
introducing you to a subject through
interactive exercises and getting you to
do practice problems give it a try based
on your understanding if you get it
wrong that's no problem you've just
improved your understanding by trying
brilliant has dozens of professionally
written courses on subjects in science
maths and computer science so if you'd
rather learn a new skill like python or
supplement you're learning in the
classroom when doing calculus there's
something for everyone I went on holiday
recently and actually tried out their
course on Quantum Computing on my phone
and it was really fun the app works
super smoothly and it was a far more
productive way to spend time on a road
trip than just playing slay the Spire
over and over again to try it for
yourself head to berlin.org Simon Clark
Linked In the description and if you're
one of the first 200 people to do so
you'll get a nice 20 off a subscription
for yourself or on a gift for someone
else that's brilliant.org Simon Clark
with thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video thank you so much for
watching the video you can probably tell
but I hope it wasn't too distracting I
have a monster cold right now so in a
couple of days I hope I can look back on
this and see that it makes sense and is
good because right now I have no clue
I'll leave you by saying if you enjoyed
the video please do give it a like give
it a share if you think other people
should see it and you can check out some
of these videos right here if you want
to see some more climate change based
content from me thank you again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one